a good morning mark your arrival on
Twitter apparently wasn't enough to
really have that exponential growth like
your very own tweed because we thought
we saw in this quarter with Twitter mark
they only grew 23% last quarter it was
twenty four percent that gets you to 284
million users and they of course have a
goal of getting to a billion or north of
a billion so clearly the stock was under
pressure and after-hours trading it was
down some ten percent yes sales were up
they hit to 361 million that beat the
analyst estimates of 351 million but
here's what the CEO said in an interview
with Bloomberg in terms of the overall
number because that's really what this
stock is being judged on it said it's
the number that we have delivered into
the market and it's our number one
priority we have an aspiration to build
the largest daily audience in the world
to get to that largest daily audience
you have to overtake facebook facebook
SAT about 1.3 billion active users that
means Twitter would have to nearly
quadruple their number of users it's a
remarkable goal a challenging task on
the good news front some of their sales
numbers were good especially on
international sales that made up about
thirty-four percent of their overall
sales a lot of Twitter's users actually
are abroad so what we've seen here in
the last 36 months is the development
mark of a sales team so you can start
selling as those international users and
that's where you come in and your
burgeoning blowing up twitter feed we
should just really have two side by side
charts Twitter stock and mark Barton's
number of followers and I bet you they
go in parallel mark